in one word in just one word what is
your professional style facilitate it
i'm here with Deron Williams who's the
point guard for or one of the point
guards I guess for the brooklyn nets
which is a new franchise right new
franchise so how long are the Nets been
playing now it's December in Brooklyn
yeah we've been playing since we started
trying to camp October first game was a
supposed to be november first then they
got because of Sandy he got pushed back
a little bit and what's it like playing
there's a new 1 billion dollar stadium
over there I haven't been in it pretty
amazing amazing the idea TR yeah I mean
there's nothing but good things being
said about the arena you know they
spared no expense they thought about
every idea that you could think about
for an arena and just made it you know
top in line so what is it like sort of
being your sort of the face of the nets
or the franchise player is there some
pressure in that especially with the new
franchise you know I mean I know there
were new jersey nets or something before
right oh it's different now you know I
mean even though we're somewhat still
the same franchise I think it's kind of
a someone identity now being in Brooklyn
and it's you know it's a little bit of
pressure and they're come you know a lot
more responsibility I think you know
especially with off the poor things that
are coming about but you know it's been
fun it's been a lot of fun and your
owner is a Russian billionaire right and
how is that what did you have a
relationship with him I mean he sees
he's one of our is one of our world
billionaires here at Forbes yes uh here
he's a great guy you know very down to
earth if you met him and talk to him you
wouldn't know he was you know a
multi-billionaire you know just just
normal guy and you know he's he's not
around a lot because he's doing a lot of
you know a lot of politics in Russia
right now he does a few things yeah few
things calm but he has another guy
that's in charge it kind of you know
runs things behind the scenes that I I'm
in contact with a lot so what you just
made a decision recently to stay with
the with the nuts and rather than you're
from dallas and you probably could have
gone back there for a similar amount of
money and so forth what drove that
decision why did you say decide to stay
with the Brooklyn Nets well I just like
the direction we were going you know I
was excited about the new arena excited
about being in New York my family has
come to love the city being you know
we've been here for over a year now
yeah close to a year and a half and you
know it's just exciting you know it's
exciting place to live you know it's
it's a different different place to live
you know there's no city like it and so
that definitely attracted me here and
then I just like I said that the way the
team was going I felt they brought in a
gray stable of players in the offseason
and which helped me resign so did jay-z
have anything to do with you say did you
pull you aside and say you come on man
say in Brooklyn or no yeah we had a lot
of conversations you know a lot of
conversation a lot of texts back before
and I definitely definitely wanted me to
stay encouraged me to stay and what's it
like being a superstar athlete in the
media capital the way well there's a lot
of you constantly in front of the
cameras probably way more than you were
another place when you talk you know
yeah you know and you thought it'd be
days where we'd have you know two three
four you know media people after after
practices here it's you know you rarely
find less than 10 you know in games it's
even more so it's definitely been a lot
more a lot more media a lot more to a
lot more scrutiny definitely but you
know it just comes with it and I knew
that when I when I signed on you seem
like you like it to somewhat agree yeah
yeah I mean depends oh I try not to read
the paper oh that's probably a four game
losing streak yes yes so let's talk
about basketball internationally for
just a second you used to play Turkey
right I did a plan and what was that
experience and what do you what do you
foresee the future of international
basketball um well my experience was
great you know during the lockout I had
the opportunity to go to Istanbul Turkey
and play for basic Tosh I had a great
great experience you know just some I
don't think I'd ever do you know if the
situation wasn't how it was so I had it
you know what I thought was gonna be a
whole year off and I didn't want to just
sit at home and not play basketball so
you know I decided to go and play
overseas and you know it's a great
experience for me not only for me but
for my family as well oh they all get
Tadeo they all went and went
international school is it was great for
my kids to see a different culture and
you know learn about you know a
different place so in terms of being an
Olympian you run two Olympic teams that
must just be an honor I can't even
imagine yeah i mean i feel honor every
time you know they asked me to play any
that picks play for you know my country
represent my
tree and you know I've had the
opportunity win two gold medals now and
that's got to mean something right he's
a lot you know it's my greatest
accomplishment as a basketball player as
athlete and it is really special so we
really only got time for two more
questions I want to just ask you a
little bit about the lockout you think
area the players please or we ever be
happy we all friends again or is it just
it was anything really accomplished by
this were the fans you know um you know
it's a touchy subject now oh he's still
I think I think I think right now we're
good you know I think if you ask the
players things could have gone a little
bit more better for us if you asked
owners things could have went better for
them so you know it's kind of a
standstill right now we have a new
contract we have to you know play that
contract out and that's what we intend
to do so in terms of if you were to give
advice to somebody who's you know maybe
in high school but this really got some
serious athletic potential what's what's
that road like from going from there to
be a professional athlete and in what we
should be consuming he'll don't make it
yeah well i think i've seen people you
know i'm growing up you know till now
that you know have all the athletic
ability in the world have all the talent
in the world they don't apply yourself
you know that everything comes so
natural to them that they don't work
hard they don't work on their game so
the biggest thing I could say is if you
have that ability if you have that skill
set you know just continue to work on
your game and get better you know you
can you can always improve